mon propos va essentiellement s'appuyer
sur un travail que nous avons mené au
cevipof avec plusieurs collègues pendant
près de maintenant plus de 12 mois un
travail un travail d' enquête en france
mais aussi dans 12 autres pays
démocratie avancée également en afrique
et sur deux territoires outre mer
mayotte et la réunion on essayait de
comprendre un petit peu qu'elle était là
la perception l'attribution de
responsabilité politique et
institutionnel des citoyens vis-à-vis de
la gestion de la crise
donc ces éléments sont trop nombreux
c'est un puits sans fond n'a pas encore
totalement terminée l'exploitation et la
compréhension de tout ce qu'on a pu
observer sur un tendon mais il ya au
moins trois éléments sur lesquels je
voudrais revenir ce matin
le premier est d'ailleurs ça a fait
l'objet de beaucoup de discussions
beaucoup de débats des controverses
académique parfois certaines sont sont
sereines et et j'irai importante
on a pu observer dès le début de la
crise que vides
dans beaucoup de pays sauf la france une
chaire à une appréciation voire même une
sur appréciation de l'activité des
exécutifs pour gérer la crise alors ça
s'est traduit beaucoup de beaucoup de
textes ont été publiés ça s'est traduit
par cette progression exponentielle de
la popularité des exécutifs président
premier ministre selon selon les pays et
parfois c'était très curieux parce que
si je prends le cas de l'italie ou même
le cas du royaume uni avant la crise
leur exécutif ne bénéficiez pas d'un
niveau de satisfaction de popularité
très élevée et crise apparaissant on a
on a vu des choses spectaculaires plus
de 20 points 30 points 40 point même de
popularité dans certains cas je mets de
côté la nouvelle zélande et l'australie
ou oulaya jetez rien aucune rationalité
alors pourquoi pourquoi la situation
française a échappé à ce mouvement de
popularité moi je vois deux deux
explications et et au fond il faut il
faut il faut être très précis la
situation elle n'est pas l' inverse de
ce qu on a pu observer dans d'autres
pays c'est à dire qu on aurait pu
observer une un décrochage aussi si la
les citoyens français avait considéré
que la gestion était était mauvaise donc
on a eu plus tôt une stabilité et 7
cette stabilité était très curieuse
parce que on sait que lorsqu'on a des
crises sévères d'une telle ampleur je
pense crise du du 11 septembre aux états
unis vague d'attentats en france en 2015
crise financière 2008 2009
en général il ya un effet de certains
appellent ça en bon en bon français
l'irlande flag aliments autour du
drapeau principe d'union nationale
alors pourquoi il s'est pas produit en
france pourquoi il n'y a pas eu cette
augmentation jeu et cette hausse de
popularité
je disais je vois trois explications la
première c'est que l'attribution de la
responsabilité d'une bonne gestion d'une
crise sanitaire qui s'est déployé sur
tout le territoire
à l'essai ce moment d'incompréhension
entre le rôle institutionnel et le rôle
politique des acteurs qu'il soit
président de la république gouvernement
est aussi chefs d'exécutifs locaux
régionaux dans une dans une
incompréhension parce que la crise n'a
pas frappé tout le territoire on le sait
un de la même manière et donc il ya eu
quand nous on a pu l'observer dans nos
enquêtes cevipof dès le mois de mars une
un niveau d'appréciation des exécutifs
locaux notamment dans le grand est et
même en région en région paca avec une
progression très rapide très rapide
durant les premières semaines
or le l'exécutif national ne bénéficiait
pas du même du même sursaut doc on voit
bien qu'il y avait et jospeh employer le
terme de différenciation parce qu'on va
y revenir tout à l'heure mais là je
l'emploie dans un autre contexte
pour moi ça me dirait que j'ai été
rassuré sur le bon fonctionnement d'une
démocratie on est capable d'attribuer la
responsabilité politique au regard d'une
situation de crise
ensuite il ya une deuxième explication
je voudrais mettre en avant cette fois
ci autour de la la perception des
citoyens sur les outils qui ont été
mobilisés pour faire face à cette crise
est là on a pu observer et notamment
plusieurs échanges avec eux la mf à ce
sujet mais on a mené une enquête auprès
de l'ensemble des maires de france en
septembre et octobre 2021
près de 5000 d'entre eux ont répondu moi
j'ai été frappé de voir que ce qui était
présenté notamment dans la presse comme
la révélation d'un couple père du préfet
maire n'était pas forcément la
perception des maires qui ont répondu à
notre enquête c'est à dire que oui ça a
fonctionné
c'est d'une certaine manière peut-être
réhabiliter les sous préfectures où ces
pierres ces institutions fantôme pour en
avoir visité un certain nombre depuis
près de trois ans et c'était d'ailleurs
une source d'insatisfaction des mers
considérant que les laits sous préfet
n'était pas en mesure de répondre à
plusieurs de leurs demandes
il ya une forme de réhabilitation du
rôle des sous préfet mais tu as un rôle
dans l'absolu un rôle pour venir se
substituer à me semble-t-il une forte
insatisfaction qui est la fois
fonctionnel mais aussi je crois en
termes de coordination avec les agences
régionales de santé
donc la question de la santé pour moi
est au coeur d'une interrogation sur
l'architecturé institutionnelle et
choisir du du territoire français en
particulier dans un texte
on en parlait en aparté avant le début
de cette audition sur la compétence
santé qui ne se retrouvent pas dans le
texte 4d à proprement parler et je
disais trois points le troisième
le troisième sujet qui me semble ici
intéressant et ça je le tiens de notre
travail du baromètre de la confiance
politique effectivement on observe que
les français n'avaient pas d'attentes
très élevé vis-à-vis du rôle des élus
locaux dans la gestion de cette crise et
lors c'est très intéressant parce que il
attribue à la fois il a la
responsabilité de d'une mauvaise gestion
de la crise en mettant en avant un le
premier ministre et son gouvernement
en tout cas les ministres concernés près
d'eux pour près d'un tiers des français
deuxièmement il met en avant le
président de la république
à 25% et puis les citoyens eux-mêmes 30%
les élus locaux sont sont considérés
responsable de la dégradation de la
crise sanitaire au cours des mois pour
seulement 1 % d'entre eux donc il faut
le citer mais c'est tout à fait
symbolique et marginal concernant à qui
attribuer la responsabilité de
l'amélioration leur amélioration il faut
faire très attention parce que c'est une
enquête qui a été administré sur le
terrain au mois d'avril 2021 donc il ya
quelques semaines
donc après quand même droit trois vagues
successives
les responsables de l'amélioration c'est
très intéressant parce qu'on retrouve un
les citoyens considérés comme
responsables de cette amélioration 2 les
scientifiques parlent expertise
mobilisés et 3 le gouvernement et les
ministres 22%
le président de la république 10% et les
élus locaux 4%
alors tout cela donne le sentiment que
les élus locaux ont été soit tenue en
marge de la gestion de la crise et je
crois que c'est un ressenti partagé par
beaucoup d'élus locaux soit au fond on
peut le voir autrement les compétences
dont dispose les élus locaux pour faire
face à cette crise n'existe pas tout
simplement j'ai eu alain lambert
président du conseil national
d'évaluation des normes
vous avez le ministre cher monsieur le
président
heureux de vous revoir mais chez les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs je
vais faire comme monsieur foucault très
vite pour respecter les limites que vous
nous avez proposé monsieur le président
en inspirant du questionnaire et en me
limitant a évoqué des perspectives sont
les développer et vous laissant le soin
de poser des questions à la suite alors
le premier enseignement que je trouve
pour ce qui des concerts qui me concerne
qui conseille ce que j'ai ressenti au
sein du cnn
c'est que le pilotage d'une politique
qui doit répondre aux besoins de chaque
foyer français en mode centralisé ne
marche pas parce que ce pilotage
centralisé lent il est uniforme il est
excessivement normes et on le comprend
lorsqu'il le vise l'ensemble de la
nation
il ne permet pas d'atteindre toutes les
cibles et il est probablement coûteux
mais c'est un autre sujet vous avez dans
votre propos introductif monsieur le
président évoqué la révision
constitutionnelle de 2003 qui a
introduit le principe d'organisation
décentralisée de la république et qui a
au fond plat c'est ce principe au même
niveau que le principe d'égalité et le
principe d'indivisibilité est d'ailleurs
l'exposé des motifs de la révision
constitutionnelle
de ce point de vue là est sans équivoque
et d'higelin si les conditions de la
mise en oeuvre du principe de
subsidiarité sont réunies et il est même
ajouté un deuxième alinéa à l'article 72
qui dispose que les collectivités ont
vocation à exercer l'ensemble des
compétences qui peuvent être le mieux
mises en oeuvre à l'échelle de leur
ressort
donc si le constituant a voulu adresser
ce message à la fois à la nation et à
ses représentants et que finalement on
continue comme avant ça n'est plus un
problème juridique
c'est un problème de comportement qu'il
nous faut réinterroger et tout ça je
voulais tout cela pour vous dire que je
pense que ça n'est pas un sujet qui
commande une révision constitutionnelle
parce que à droits constitutionnels du
constant nous pouvons faire beaucoup
mieux que ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui lors s'agissant du principe
d'égalité
mon propos sera un peu différent de
celui de monsieur foucault j'ai tout à
fait confiance dans le caractère
scientifique naturellement de ses études
mais en tant qu'élu local et à partir du
témoignage des autres des yeux logo le
rapport des français au principe
d'égalité c'est qu'ils y tiennent
beaucoup lorsqu'il leur permet d'avoir
au moins la même chose que les autres
mais en tout cas ils sont assez
indifférent à l'égalité des autres en
conséquence moi je pense que le sujet du
principe d'égalité appliquée à la santé
puisque c'est votre sujet je pense qu'il
s'agit en france d'un tabou juridique et
qu'il savait opportun de tenter sinon de
lever en tout cas des l'explicité en
s'appuyant d'abord sur la jurisprudence
du conseil constitutionnel
mais en essayant à mes yeux de la rendre
encore plus explicite pour lever des
verrous de résistance que je qualifie d'
pavlovienne selon une formulation que je
tiens d'ailleurs à votre disposition
parce que le cnn a écrit quelque chose
sur ce sujet s'agissant de
l'intervention des collectivités dans le
domaine de la santé alors je veux bien
entendre qu' elle n'a pas été aperçu par
les français en tout état de cause les
élus ont été beaucoup interrogé en ce
qui les concerne et il n'avait pas
toujours d'ailleurs la réponse aux
questions qu'on leur pose et je crois
que l'intervention des collectivités
dans le domaine de la santé est tout à
fait salutaire pour sortir déjà d'un
corporatisme
en tout cas j'assume cette approche du
sujet parce que j'ai vécu dans mes
fonctions
nommons département d'un corporatisme
dans lequel le ministère de la santé
persiste à s'emprisonner entre la
médecine libérale et la médecine
salariée hospitalière alors que nous
avons une bombe à retardement que
représente la démographie médicale et
qui exige que des partenariats se nouent
entre l'hôpital et la médecine de ville
et que pour l'instant ces partenariats
se heurte parfois à des règles ou
législative ou réglementaire donc je
vous indique qu'elle rende ses
partenariats kafkaïen et dans certains
cas on y renonce
s'agissant des modalités je vais très
vite à ça fait partie de notre contrat
et après vous pourrez dans le débat est
lentement mais demande et de
l'approfondir
s'agissant des modalités je
recommanderais pour ma part qu'il ne
soit pas fait d'attribution de
compétences à un échelon territorial et
que l'exercice de cette compétence soit
ouvert à tous les types de coopération
s'agissant par exemple de la médecine de
ville selon la taille des collectivités
et du nombre de patients à traiter aprue
à prendre en charge des solutions
différentes sont déjà existantes mais
peuvent être améliorées qu'il s'agisse
des pc là des raisons de santé des
centres de santé mais actuellement les
cofinancements entre échelons
territoriaux
ou se passe plutôt bien parce
précisément parce que ils ne sont pas
trop régie par le droit
s'agissant des ars plutôt qu'un mix de
gouvernance qui risque d'aggraver le
pilotage actuelle qui est déjà mes yeux
chaotique
je me demande si au fond un conseil de
surveillance ne serait pas plus
approprié
certes ces pouvoirs seraient limités
mais il exercerait un contrôle et une
vigie qui permettrait de faire des
propositions sur les orientations
choisies par les ars
le jeu doit hier quand même si ça n'a
rien à voir j'ai siégé pendant plus de
dix ans à la commission de surveillance
de la caisse des dépôts et consignations
il était intéressant d'observer comment
les parlementaires qui sont chargés de
la surveillance précisément de la
décision prise conjointement par la
direction du trésor et par la direction
générale de la caisse des dépôts sont
tout à fait intéressante
s'agissant des hôpitaux j'ai un peu le
même réflexe naturellement il existait
déjà un conseil de surveillance
mais je me méfie toujours des douze le
pilotage parce que ce n'est pas de bonne
méthode
et c est probablement l'ancien
parlementaire engagée dans les finances
publiques qui le pense parce que le
doubs le pilotage sa partage là l'esprit
de responsabilité
en revanche le pilote doit pouvoir
rendre compte en temps réel au conseil
qui est chargée de la surveillance des
décisions qu'il prend et des
orientations qu'elle choisit pour
l'avenir de l'établissement des
établissements s'agissant des échelons
territoriaux qui exerce cette
surveillance je ne suis pas favorable
depuis toujours vous le savez monsieur
le président à la théorie des blocs de
compétences qui confère un échelon et à
un seul des prérogatives qui impacte à
territoire qui est beaucoup plus vaste
que le siège de
la collectivité territoriale concernée
si on en croit je pense que ces conseils
devraient être désignés par des par les
collectivités du ressort de chaque
établissement
selon d'ailleurs des systèmes de deux
représentations qui permettent à toutes
les sensibilités à tous les territoires
de pouvoir être entendue on voit bien à
travers les les opci paru yen s'est pas
toujours dans la facilité jeu j'en
conviens messi est la preuve que c'est
possible alors s'agissant des
financements
on parle de seulement encore je pense
qu'il faut éviter d'instaurer des règles
trop contraignantes
aujourd'hui les collectivités
interviennent déjà beaucoup dans le
domaine de la santé sans contrepartie
pour l'instant des finances de l'état je
pense que l'instauration d'un transfert
de ressources
s'il y avait un transfert législatives
de compétences ne serait vraiment
justifiée que dans le cas où il
s'agirait de transfert de compétences
obligatoires
à défaut je pense qu'il ne faut surtout
pas ce que nous priver de l'authie
contractuels ou conventionnelle que nous
utilisons actuellement et qui est à mes
yeux très approprié seules existent déjà
avec les centres de santé avec les
maisons de santé avec l'assurance
maladie
voilà dans le petit département dont je
suis l'élu c'est le conseil
départemental qui financent
l'hélicoptère qui relie l'hôpital au chu
enfin contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser les collectivités territoriales
sont déjà très engagé dans le
financement de la santé
s'agissant enfin des relations
financières entre l'état et les
collectivités
il me semble qu'un armistice serait lui
est venue car l'enjeu de la reprise est
tellement important que nous devons
éviter tout élément de division mais
nous constatons au cnn beaucoup moins de
transferts massifs de dépenses entre
l'état et les collectivités
mais en contrepartie nous constatons une
dérive et qui devient très inquiétante
c'est celle des coûts masqué d'énormes
de plus en plus nombreuses qui pleuvent
dans le domaine des compétences qui ont
été transférées par l'état
on a parfois le sentiment que le
prescripteur à puisqu'il n'est plus
désormais le payeur impose des normes de
plus en plus nombreuses et de plus en
plus coûteuses
tentons plan administratif que technique
et ses normes soit 200 de plus en plus
n'ont pas évalué au motif que le
prescripteur prétend qu'il n'a pas
l'appareil statistique pour pouvoir
évaluer ses coûts puisque les
compétences ont été transférées et cela
me permet mais c'est le président
d'achever mon propos en portant votre
connaissance que nous avons engagé un
partenariat avec notre homologue
allemand qui le nkm et et is ce pack i7
homologue dispose lui de l'accès à
l'organe statistiques qui était
équivalent à l'insee il a un pouvoir de
saisine pour réaliser des évaluations de
charge des nouvelles réglementations
ce mode d'évaluation a été instauré dans
une loi fédérale qui s'est intitulé
mieux légiférer
elle a consisté à se doter d'un outil
d'évaluation qui ne soient pas
contestées
et pour calculer les coûts qui sont
engendrées par les nouvelles
législations par les nouvelles
réglementations voix par les compétences
qui sont transférées il s'agit pas
seulement d'études etc santé mais aussi
d'études et ex post
et c'est cette nouvelle façon de
travailler avec un organe comme l'insee
qui est à la disposition donc des
institutions représentatives des
collectivités territoriales ont permis
de réduire le corpus normatif sensible
très sensiblement notamment en obligeant
les administrations centrales à sublimer
à supprimer des obligations anciennes
qui était devenu superflu ou financer et
qui permettent de financer bien sûr les
nouvelles mesures
donc nous pouvons toujours apprendre de
ce que font les autres
voilà ce que je voulais elle vous dira
en introduction et entendez que sur
chaque sujet que j'ai évoqués je peux
bien entendu répondre à vos questions ou
de suite
au maire de dunkerque je ne vois plus
sur l'écran mais il devrait être là
monsieur lemay jour bonjour quand vous
avez la parole merci merci merci de
m'avoir invité non dans ce débat j'ai
envie d'intervenir en vous livrant
effectivement l'expérience qui a été la
mienne sur le terrain depuis depuis mars
2020 est ce que j'en ai retiré en x 4
fois d'abord à la question est ce que
les collectivités ont gagné en confiance
vis-à-vis des populations des acteurs
économiques des acteurs sanitaires
la réponse est évidemment oui
c'est à dire au delà de est ce que la
population a perçu si on était
responsable de l'amélioration de la
crise ce qui est clair c'est que la
confiance politique en les élus locaux
s'est accentuée avec la crise sanitaire
peau trois raisons à mon avis la
première c'est que les élus locaux ont
réussi à montrer aux populations aux
acteurs sanitaires une plus grande
efficacité une plus grande réactivité et
il était dans le concret quand dès le
mois de mars
nos infirmières nos médecins se
plaignait d'un manque de matériel
ce sont les élus locaux qui leur fournit
le matériel nécessaire est évidemment ça
a joué considérablement dans la
confiance entre les élus locaux et ses
acteurs quand il s'est agit de répondre
à la question de l'accès à un certain
nombre de droits
ce sont les collectivités qui ont été en
première ligne je vais donner deux
exemples mi mars 2020 toutes les
institutions des lots plus démunis ferme
sauf le ccrs c'est à dire qu'à ce moment
là si la ville n'est pas là les plus
démunis peuvent mourir de faim dans
l'âme or c'est la ville qui est là pour
apporter son aide
quand il faut prendre en charge des
enfants de soignants au qu'un
instituteur
aucun professeur n'était présent le
premier jour pour garder les enfants
soignants ce sont les animals
de la ville qui ont assuré la garde des
enfants seraient donc évidemment cette
réactivité cette efficacité elle a
marqué profondément les populations et
les actes la deuxième raison pour
laquelle il ya eu confiance envers les
élus locaux c'est finalement les élus
l'ont été dans le dialogue avec les
acteurs locaux et la population et
surtout dans le sens c'était bien quand
ils mettaient quelque chose en neuf
la proximité leur donner la possibilité
d'expliquer expliquer pourquoi on
mettait en oeuvre tel ou tel type
d'action et ça évidemment cette question
du sens elle est fondamentale
aujourd'hui on ne veut plus diriger un
pays sans donner le sens des mesures au
mais on y est évidemment depuis bari
donner du sens c'est compliqué et enfin
il ya eu un troisième élément alain kert
ça a été la laërt
quand le variant anglais a fortement
touché le territoire dunkerquois ce qui
nous a d'ailleurs valu les la primauté
des de télévision nationale c'est le
maire ces derniers mois même à travers
une vidéo qui alertent ma population sur
la présence des variants anglais ce qui
est une situation totalement anormale
basque en peluche et même pas accès aux
statistiques c'est moi qui dois refaire
un travail pour essayé d'alerter sur la
présence du mari en anglais et sur le
risque ça représente pour notre
territoire
évidemment cette alerte dans la
transparence a été apprécié en termes de
confiance par la population et les
acteurs lot no he will et collectivités
ont largement gagné en confiance
deuxième point mon intervention l'état
en fait
le paradoxe c'est que l'état s'est
montré très généreux dans cette crise
sanitaire
mais il s'est fourvoyé sur tout ce qui
concerne assure dans trois domaines dans
trois domaines où il a complètement mis
de côté les élus locaux on a été
complètement mis en marche dans trois
domaines qui me paraissent elles les
grandes erreurs de l'est par la crise m
le premier domaine c'est la prévention
qui est une responsabilité des
collectivités locales on n'explique pas
les gestes barrière à tf1 à la
télévision on les explique pas ce qu'une
personne vous regarde pour
les yeux et on a complètement oublié ne
renvoyer aux collectivités locales et
aux terrains la question de la
prévention notamment par rapport aux
gestes barrières mais s'il viendrait
dans mon dernier poids le deuxième
élément sur lequel l'état s'est
complètement fourvoyé c'est la gestion
du quotidien
l'organisation des marchés mais qu'est
ce que l'état vient dans
l'organisation des marchés mois chez moi
j'ai une plage je sais pas quel élan
douilles excusez moi l'expression qui a
inventé la plage dynamique mais je me
suis retrouvé à les confiner au moins 10
mai 2020 et je propose un plan de
déconfinement au préfet qu'ils étaient
d'accord et abandonner une vie mais tu
sais en loire atlantique il son
département vert et ils ont inventé le
concept de la plage dynamique on a le
droit de s'asseoir et gym et michel moi
j'ai les kilomètres carrés de plage et
si je fais une blague dynamique tout le
monde va s'asseoir sur la l'idée serait
de la concentration des populations
il m'a dit c'est comme ça à toi tu es
département rouge tu dois faire au moins
ce que font les bons pendant une semaine
j'ai pas dû gérer ma plage c'était la
catastrophe et le préfet a dû faire
marche arrière parce que tout simplement
ça n'avait pas de sens et qu'on
appliquait ce qui se faisait en loire
atlantique
donc la question de la gestion du
quotidien
l'état s'est complètement fourvoyé là
non il fallait le renvoyer aux acteurs
locaux en les laissant assumer cette
responsabilité qu'ils amènent des
garde-fous veto du préfet consensus des
mères à l'échelle d'un lexique tout
aurait pu être imaginé mais il fallait
renvoyer cette gestion du quotidien au
niveau look et enfin dernier point les
signaux faibles mois sur le vario
anglais j'ai été le premier territoire
touché fortement par le vaillant où il
ya des signaux faibles qui sont capables
on a vu par exemple que les enfants
étaient plus contagieux j'ai fait passer
des messages y compris au ministre lui
même
on n'a pas reconnu aux élus locaux la
pertinence des signaux faibles et ces
trois semaines plus tard ou quatre
semaines plus tard qu'on entend à la
télévision tout ce qu'on a dit à l'état
à ce qu'on vivait une situation qui
était différente de celle du territoire
national et c'est le question des
signaux seul je le regrette parce que
dans la chasse
virus s'appuyer sur les signaux faibles
c'est fondamental derniers mois de mon
propos finalement qu'est-ce qui a révélé
cette crise sanitaire de notre de notre
système de santé
d'abord un virus à la lutte contre un
virus c'est d'abord de la prévention
finalement pour bien lutter contre un
virus il faut empêcher qui se diffuse
finalement est donc là on est
complètement dans le domaine de la
prévention les gestes barrières et
essayer de faire évoluer les
comportements des populations et le gros
problème c'est notre système de santé il
est fondé sur la maladie et pas sur la
prévention
nous soignons la maladie nous traitons
les malades et on a vu toute la
faiblesse de notre système de santé
j'entendais quelqu'un tout à l'heure qui
misait parlé de coordination la force
d'un système c'est sa coordination mais
il n'y a pas de coordination aujourd'hui
il ya d'un côté les collectivités
locales qui ont une responsabilité en
matière de prévention et de l'autre côté
un système de santé qui s'occupe de la
maladie le problème c'est qu'il faut
relier les deux ont réussi à le faire en
matière de sécurité aujourd'hui police
municipale police nationale sont en
train de s'intégrer par mois sur mon
territoire suis frappé de voir la
coordination qui est en train de se
passer à quel point le ceux qui aiment
bien
c'est un échec dans l'éducation
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de mal à
articuler l'action des collectivités
locales avec l'éducation nationale
c'est un échec aussi dans la santé il
faut lui dire quand va-t-on réussir à
construire un système de santé qui va
réussir à intégrer la prise en charge
globale de la personne avec en même
temps la prévention et le soin et cette
question là aujourd'hui elle est
absolument pas tranchée donc plus qu'un
transfert de compétences moi j'attends
une réforme en profondeur notre système
de santé qui au lieu en fait de traiter
la maladie va traiter la santé et je
pense que ça c'est l'assèchement d'un
mental et enfin le dernier et toi je
vais conclure là dessus notre l'autre
ceux qui sanitaire a aussi révélé des
malaises au fond dans la logique du
système administré la santé n'est pas
donc les pas fondés sur le marché et
fondé sur un système à les ministres
ici c'est ma miss très montre quand même
de grandes failles à tel point qu'on va
bientôt finir par être un pays d'orthe
aux dentistes
il ya des rémunérations qui sont
anormales l'argent ne va pas là où est
le besoin de la population
aujourd'hui il oriente le système de
santé vers des choses qui ne sont ni la
prévention lui forcément ce dont a
besoin la population ce qui est la
faiblesse d'un système administré on le
sait un système à nice très n'ai jamais
pu réparé fait mais aujourd'hui
particulièrement un parfait et je crains
d'ailleurs pour les années qui viennent
une désinfection profonde de certains
métiers de soignants moi j'ai du mal à
recruter à la ville d'oullins cas des
infirmières
aujourd'hui parce qu'elles ne veulent
plus exercer ce métier et je pense que
quand on aura toujours des
orthodontistes en france donc on aura
les belles dents mais par contre on
n'aura plus ces métiers qui sont
absolument indispensables au quotidien
donc je pense qu'il est urgent de revoir
profondément le système à nuits d'istres
et l'orientation financières du système
de santé pour redonner de l'attractivité
à certain nombre de métiers est aussi
intégré la question des conditions de
travail
et là on aura besoin des collectivités
aussi pour rendre la médecine le métier
soignants beaucoup plus attractif je
reviendrai pas sur la question des
moyens mais s'il ya les questions jeu
avec plaisir j'y reviens très bien je
vous remercie monsieur le maire et je
donne la parole notre dernier
intervenant jeu jean marie pons qui est
professeur émérite à l'université
d'aix-en-provence j'espère qu'ils
mentent temps et de je lui donne la
parole tout de suite
merci monsieur le président je vous
entends et je vous rends en revanche je
pense que vous ne voyez pas je ne sais
pas pourquoi il y à cette espèce de
blizzard boulons à la place de la photo
qui devrait être la mienne
j'en suis désolé alors qu'ils les
questions qui m'étaient posées porté sur
deux champs en fait d'une part la
question des interventions sanitaires et
d'autre part la loi notre ans et ses
conséquences si vous voulez je discret
ne dispose pour l'instant que de huit
minutes
je parle seulement de la première partie
ce qui concerne le champ sanitaire
vous préférez en regroupant les
questions qui ont été posées
de ce point de vue faire deux séries
d'observations première série
d'observations
il me semble mois que d'une manière
générale les élus locaux sont sortis
confortée de cette pandémie
je serais tenté de dire que la pandémie
a été un véritable révélateur au sens
chimique déterrement en ce sens que les
élus locaux - dans la perception que je
n ai pas fait une enquête mais et
regarder un peu autour de moi les élus
locaux ont été mis en valeur par la
pandémie en quelques sortes en cette
pandémie a servi les élus locaux
même si ce n'est pas dans la même
proportion pour l'ensemble des élus
locaux
en ce qui concerne les élus régionaux et
plus exactement à tellement l'ensemble
des élus régionaux mais les présidents
de conseil régional
ces présidents ont été connus des
citoyens par les initiatives qu'ils ont
pu prendre tout au moins certains
d'entre eux et ceci quel qu'ait été le
bien fondé ou pas de ces initiatives
de même les rend plus inattendus les
départements ont également bénéficié de
la pandémie
je voudrais citer en particulier les
départements qui ont mis en place des
bus des bus départementaux qui ont
sillonné les départements en
transportant les vaccins il me semble
que ce sont les maires tient paraissent
comme ayant été les autorités locales
ont le plus mises en lumière par
l'épidémie les verts ont pris des
initiatives
ils ont fait des démarches ils ont
adopté les dispositions pour que leurs
populations puissent être vaccinés et
j'ai constaté une chose remarquable
1 c'est à dire que les maires de petites
communes n'ont pas été les derniers
agir et sans eux sans ces mères la
vaccination lancerait pas là où elle
allait aujourd'hui pour résumer sur ce
point je dirais que les élus locaux ont
fait preuve dans le mot était utilisé
par le maire de dunkerque oui on fait
preuve de réactivité
ils ont démontré leur utilité
ils ont montré leur efficacité pour moi
une double démonstration est faite des
faits de cette épidémie à la suite cette
épidémie démonstration qui va à
l'encontre des politiques menées depuis
de nombreuses années en ce sens que les
petites communes ont démontré leur
utilité leur caractère indispensable à
la fois sur le plan sanitaire comme sur
le plan social la suppression ou la
volonté de suppression de ces petites
communes
à mon avis a été ou selon tran une
mauvaise chose de même les départements
fortement contestés ont fait la preuve
de leur utilité
la question de leur suppression selon
moi ne devrait plus être d'actualité
d'une manière générale les structures
locales décentralisées ont fait la
preuve en de leur capacité à réagir et à
tenir face à une crise grave
de ce fait le semble-t-il la confiance
dans les institutions locales le plus
que s'en trouver renforcée et j'ai vu
les réactions
bien entendu ce ne sont pas des enquêtes
mais les réactions d'un certain nombre
de personnes passant aux actions des
élus locaux notamment des maires et ses
réactions des gens étaient extrêmement
favorable les gens n'ont pu que
féliciter leur mère des actions t en
propre mais je n'en dirai pas de même
des structures de l'état
même si l'on sait que ces dernières ont
dû face à des difficultés considérables
et imedi deuxième série de remarques sur
le plan de la santé
les élus locaux aurait-il dû
être mieux associés à la lutte contre la
pandémie aux décisions relatives aux
restrictions de liberté à leur levée
aurait tendance à distinguer et à
nuancer tout d'abord je voudrais faire
observer que l'évolution depuis bien des
années est allé dans le sens d'une
centralisation de la politique sanitaire
et d'ailleurs si vous lisez un certain
nombre de revues certaines mes collègues
ont écrit des articles en saveur de
cette centralisation
disons qu'il ne pouvait pas en être
autrement
jusqu'en 2009 l'hôpital avait encore un
statut communal et c'est à partir de
2009 la loi de 2009 que l'on a mis fin à
ce statut par ailleurs en 1983 le
législateur a attribué des compétences
en matière de santé au département et il
est apparu que ce n'était pas
satisfaisant et vous souvenez que la loi
du 13 août 2004 à recentraliser un
certain nombre de ses compétences
notamment relativement aux campagnes de
vaccination et à la lutte contre les
grandes maladies
un jour ici tu es quand même c'est la
loi c'est le parlement qui a adopté cet
article l 1411 en tirer 1 du code de
santé publique qui dispose de manière
très claire très explicite la politique
de santé relevant de la responsabilité
de l'état
l'argument le plus fort qui a été
invoqué en faveur de la maîtrise de
santé par l'état
et évidemment le principe d'égalité
principe d'égalité qui est un principe
constitutionnel et qui est associé à un
autre principe constitutionnel qu'est ce
qu'on appelle le droit à la santé lequel
région
[Musique]
tu peux de l'alinéa 11 du préambule de
46 qui a valeur constitutionnelle comme
vous savez cette prégnance ans du
principe d'égalité
la force de ce principe d'égalité est
considérable dans notre pays beaucoup
plus sans doute que dans les pays anglo
saxons alors s'il y avait eu cette
centralisation
je voudrais cependant rappelé trois
points
d'abord ce qui est du champ du sanitaire
ne se distingue pas toujours très bien
de ce qui est social il ya par exemple
le champ du médico-social est prise en
compte par différents textes
si on regarde par exemple l'article l
trois mises sens terrien des code de
l'action sociale et des familles il y
ait un développement sur le médico
social
il est alors difficile d'affirmer de
manière péremptoire qu'il y aurait d'un
côté le sanitaire qui ne relèveraient et
de l'autre le social qui lui relève
aurait largement des collectivités
territoriales deuxièmement des
instruments ont été prévues par le
législateur dans le domaine de la santé
au profit des collectivités
territoriales
ainsi par exemple l'article l 1434 10 du
code de la santé publique prévoit
l'adoption par les régions d'un projet
régional de santé et ce dernier le
projet régional de santé peut faire
l'objet lui-même de contrats locaux de
santé passé entre les ars et les
collectivités territoriales
mais que sont ces instruments en réalité
sont des instruments ambigu parce que
leur contenu est très vague
ou bien il est creux et l'on peut se
demander s'il ne s'agit pas de simples
colifichets que l'on agite devant les
collectivités territoriales on peut se
demander s'il ne s'agit pas de simples
moyens pour faire payer les
collectivités territoriales
troisièmement l'expérience de la
pandémie a montré que sans les
collectivités territoriales et plus
précisément sans les communes l'état
aurait été bien en peine de mener sa
politique de confinement et de
déconfinement et sa politique de
vaccination
les ars ne se sont pas montrés des
instruments efficaces à lavey h en le
couplant préfet leur a souvent assez
bien fonctionné
alors faut-il
filles et les dispositifs existants le
sénat a fait une proposition dans un
document 2020 qui est intitulé pour une
politique générale de la
décentralisation et cette proposition
consisterait à confier la présidence des
ars un élu local
je suis extrêmement sceptique sur cette
proposition pour les raisons suivantes
d'une part le conseil constitutionnel a
déclaré qu'aucune exigence
constitutionnelle le garantis c'est
l'autonomie de gestion des
établissements de santé cela dans une
décision de 2009
d'autre part le conseil d'état lui a
déclaré que les directeurs des ars
étaient soumis au pouvoir hiérarchique
des ministres concernés dans une
décision de 2012 comment dans ces
conditions les élus locaux
pourrait-il avoir une influence sur les
ars il faut modifier ou bien la journée
l'espérance le liquidateur peut très
bien aller à l'encontre cette
jurisprudence
ou bien à l'opt et d'autres dispositions
pour donner un rôle par yann aux élus
locaux
non je pense que les élus locaux n'ont
pas actuellement de compétences en
matière de santé mais il est possible
d'améliorer la situation
il me semble qu'il y ait au moins deux
choses qu'il faudrait faire et que la
long d'une part assurer une information
que les autorités de l'état assure une
information des élus locaux dans toutes
les décisions que ces autorités prennent
dans le domaine de la santé
et d'autre part il me semble qu'il
serait possible d'établir une
concertation
lorsque une décision doit être prise à
associer les élus locaux
même sans que leur avis soit un avis
conforme c'est à dire que ce soit qui
s'imposent mais com - soient consultés
qu'ils puissent donner leur sentiment
sur les
durand qui doivent être prises et si
l'on voulait ont par exemple en matière
de confinement déconfinement nous sommes
dans le domaine de la matière de ce
qu'on appelle juridiquement la police
dès lors qu'ils série de liberté c'est
les élus locaux ne peuvent avoir aucune
compétence dans le confinement ce n'est
pas eux qui peuvent le décider même le
législateur est limité puisque en
portent atteinte à des libertés qui sont
fondamentales qui ont valeur
constitutionnelle est actuellement la
jurisprudence en elle qu'elle et déclare
que les autorités de police enp
inférieur ne peuvent qu'aggraver les
décider les dispositions prises par
l'autorité de police supérieur et non
pas les atténuer mais hambourg et dans
le cadre de du déconfinement puisque on
pourrait imaginer un déconfinement si la
situation se reproduit qui soit
différenciée selon les territoires
on pourrait imaginer que les élus locaux
puissent adopter telle décision mais il
faudrait une loi pour mettre fin à cette
jurisprudence
il n'est pas possible à l'heure actuelle
que les élus locaux puissent procéder de
cette manière là voilà je crois que j'ai
épuisé mais huit minutes monsieur le
président est donc après pour le reste
si vous souhaitez vous posez des
questions que je suis dispo les y répond
merci je vais tout de suite donné la
parole à jean michel arnaud rapporteur
pour s'abattre une question jean
poserait quelques unes vous prendrez
enfin ceux qui le souhaitent parmi nos
quatre intervenants répondront aux
questions des deux rapporteurs
ensuite je prendrai les questions de nos
collègues quand visioconférence ou en
présentiel et un merci je présente le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs merci
de vos interventions
il me semble en faisant la synthèse de
rapide de ce que j'ai cru comprendre vos
interventions qui a d'abord visiblement
une distorsion entre la perception que
les élus locaux
je suis moi même élu local avant de la
gestion de la crise la manière dont nous
sommes impliqués la manière dont nous
avons eu la reconnaissance de nos
citoyens et les propos tenus par martial
foucault qui semble contredire la
perception travers des enquêtes plus
scientifique de ce ressenti de la part
de nos populations et
première observation qui est en fait une
question est ce que finalement monsieur
foucault la situation de la gestion de
cette crise et finalement révélateur
d'une une déconnexion de la confiance
générale des citoyens à l'égard des
institutionnels
quand bien même notamment dans l'hyper
proximité les élus locaux c'est à saint
michel de proximité du quotidien du
premier quart d'heure en conclut
sentiment de faire le travail et je puis
vous attestez qu'ils ont fait est
pourtant globalement
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont également
contestées comme eux
tous les corps intermédiaires les
affiches elles le sont dans ce pays donc
j'aimerais éventuellement que vous
puissiez d'approfondir ce point chez
foucault et nous expliquer finalement
les grands grands éléments fondamentaux
de ce décrochage des citoyens à l'égard
des institutions
le deuxième sujet qui marquent fortement
vos interventions et finalement un
presque consensus sur le fait que le
cadre juridique à quelques détails près
permet de faire face à un certain nombre
d'attentes et d'enjeux en matière
d'accompagnement de crise et notamment
le christ qu'au vide mais que le
problème principal se situerait dans la
collaboration dans l'interconnexion des
différents silos pour une meilleure
efficacité des politiques publiques en
voit dans la loi cadre et en particulier
qui va venir à l'ordre du jour du
parlement
une prise de conscience certes marginal
une prise de conscience à travers
notamment cette notion de contrat de
contractualisation territoriale
envisager de cette nécessité
voilà de deux mètres en cohésion de
mettre en mouvement des collaborations à
6 yonnais les territoriales et vous
l'avez vous même dit la difficulté pour
les élus locaux notamment est derrière
cette contractualisation le sentiment
parfois de devoir assumer dans la
proximité des actions qui relèvent de
leur champ d'action mais avec la
contractualisation une forme de marché
du puisque les moyens ne suivent pas
vous avez évoqué notamment ceux foucault
la question autonomie financière qui est
un vrai sujet pour les collectivités
locales
et finalement les élus locaux ont le
sentiment une nouvelle fois qu'on les
prend pour des sous-traitants sans marge
de manoeuvre en ayant l'incapacité de
pouvoir agir dans la réactivité comme ça
a été dit par le maire de dunkerque la
plus absolue des attentes ddd moyens
voulus attendu par par les concitoyens
donc comment travailler sur cette notion
de contractualisation de collaboration
pour être plus efficace et plus en
confiance et que nos concitoyens
dernier sujet ça a été longuement
évoquée
par le ministre lambert
c'est effectivement la question des
drones les signalements ce que disait
l'honneur de dunkerque faisait quoi cela
toutes proportions gardées sur la
gestion du marché la gestion des plages
comment travailler la poutre entre
responsabilités locales adaptations
locales et finalement un rappel
systématique fait notamment par les
autorités qu'elles soient de la rs sur
le domaine de la santé ou de manière
plus générale par les préfectures de
département sur la fois une nécessité de
rester dans un cadre rigide et comment
travailler cette tension entre absolue
nécessité de pouvoir adapter aux
territoires des textes et des pratiques
attendue par les citoyens pourra
répondre concrètement aux besoins
d'urgence notamment en cas de crise et
ce rappel permanent et la traîne
finalement de judiciarisation de
contentieux
si on sort du cadre pour l'allée des
trois questions
principal et observations que je
souhaitais faire et j'attends évidemment
avec intérêt vos réponses sachant que
notre travail vise également à formuler
un certain nombre de recommandations et
nous sommes évidemment de trauner de de
toute recommandation vous pourriez faire
pour améliorer l'ensemble du dispositif
de réponse institutionnelle locale
vous êtes du genre une crise comme comme
la crise pourvu que nous venons de vivre
merci j'avais sept mois je veux
seulement posé deux questions la
première je vais reprendre le terme
employé par alain lambert d'armistice il
faudrait un armistice entre les
collectivités territoriales et l'état
parce que avec la crise sanitaire la
pandémie les difficultés sont telles
devant nous que ça il faut trouver des
solutions de partage et d'avenir
alors justement et je pose la question à
tous les intervenants pas seulement au
ministre lambert si on dit armistice on
a un peu le sentiment que
il faut être au moins deux pour signer
l'armistice et donc il faut que chacun
fasse un pas les collectivités locales
dans cette pandémie
on fait beaucoup en ne recevant pas
forcément beaucoup de compliments de la
part de l'état l'état a voulu garder la
main et a effectivement dans bien des
cas laisser les collectivités locales se
débrouiller localement dans des
conditions difficiles
quelle serait la notion que l'on
pourrait imaginer alors on peut parler
de concertation j'ai bien compris que la
notion même de transfert complet de
compétences en matière de santé très
difficile mais qu'est ce que l'on peut
imaginer
et comment est ce qu'on peut imaginer un
partage ou une concertation une
complémentarité entre les collectivités
territoriales et l'état qui dans le
domaine de la santé ferait en sorte que
l'an sorte par le haut si je puis dire
de cette pandémie et que l'on prévoit au
mieux
simone par malheur il y avait de
nouvelles épidémies ce que l'on prévoit
au mieux comment faire en sorte que la
réactivité comme l'a dit le maire de dan
care soit rapide et qu'on n'est pas
cesser ces zones d'attenté de turbulence
qu'on a eue toute l'année 2020 et même
des bus de ville 21
deuxième question alors là elle est un
peu plus matérielles 6 plus dire enfin
matérielle et juridique
on voit bien que
les différents textes qui se sont
succédé de décentralisation depuis 30
ans bientôt 40 ans ne sont pas abouti
mon sentiment profond c'est que le texte
en tout cas ce que nous connaissons il
est par définition pas encore passer
devant le parlement
le test de l'oac hâte d en réalité
change peu les équilibres qui sont ceux
d'aujourd'hui
on attendait de ce texte non pas une
révolution mais enfin une évolution en
tout cas très sensible à la fois des
rapports de force des rapports
financiers de rééquilibrage des pouvoirs
on a un peu le sentiment que c'est très
cosmétique et que sous couvert de faire
un texte de décentralisation en réalité
feu on va pas changer la notion d'
équilibre entre l'état et les
collectivités
est-ce que restons-en même au domaine de
la santé mais au delà peut-être de
manière plus globale
vous auriez alors vous demande pas de
rentrer dans dans le vif du sujet du
texte 4d mais qu'est-ce qui vous
apparaîtrait comme un équilibre plus
normal c'est celui qui vaudrait un
armistice jeu ministre qu'est ce qui
serait un équilibre plus normal entre
l'état et les collectivités pour la
gestion des crises je mets crise au sens
global pas seulement sanitaire peut-être
futur mans mais qu'est ce qui vaudrait
un armistice parce que pour le moment
c'est vrai depuis que je suis au sénat
monsieur le ministre et bessieux la
lutte entre les collectivités locales et
l'état est une réalité
année après année texte après texte on
est toujours en train de dire ça ne va
pas la relation est déséquilibrée
l'état ne fait pas confiance les
tendances surpasser l'état ne finance
pas assez
l'état dit oui mais les collectivités
sont dépensières les collectivités ne ne
reste pas toujours dans un cadre normal
on a un peu l'impression que la guérilla
est à collectivité n'a pas cessé depuis
plus de 20 ans et pourtant il faudrait
pour tout le monde
une relation plus sereine dans l'avenir
si on veut pouvoir travailler quelles
que soient les options politiques de
chacun comment vous voyez tout cela je
vous laisse la parole est naturellement
comme vous êtes des génies de la
concision
je vous laisse la capacité de répondre
en très peu de temps chacun avant de
donner la parole à nos collègues
sénateurs qui veut la parole à prendre
parce que là ya pas monsieur foucault
peut-être en premier allez merci
alors concision quatre minutes est-ce
que c'est satisfaisant parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de points et je me permettrai
de peut-être de vous envoyer par écrit
les autres les autres éléments de
réponse moi je vais retenir 3 3
questions
premièrement je maintiens que il y a
oui un décalage entre la perception il
s'agit pas de dire que le témoignage du
maire de dunkerque et de dizaines
d'autres mères seraient serez faut c'est
pas ça mon poing et de dire que quand on
dit que les élus locaux ont bénéficié en
termes de confiance par cette crise je
crois que c'est une erreur pourquoi
parce que les mères étaient jusqu'à
présent l'institution étaient les
acteurs politiques les plus appréciés en
termes de confiance par les français on
était déjà très très haut et donc 65% et
celle depuis prés de près de 10 ans il
ya eu un petit un petit décrochage entre
2016 et l'hiver l'hiver jaune donc
aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur un
phénomène de rattrapage pour tous les
autres acteurs politiques une
progression le conseiller départemental
le conseiller régional le député le
sénateur ont sur sont vraiment depuis
deux ans sur un mouvement à la hausse
est donc cette crise a gelé confirmé ce
mouvement de rattrapage
ça c'est le premier point une fois dit
cela cette confiance
comment elles tombent pas du ciel c'est
la confiance des citoyens vis-à-vis de
l'action publique des élus locaux
j'ai toujours considéré qu'il y avait
deux ressort à cette confiance
1 la proximité je vais le je vais le
décliner et deuxièmement la compétence
la proximité c'est ce qui a été
parfaitement dit tout à l'heure c'est
qu'effectivement ça va mais les dés des
questions de de réactivité de capacité à
observer un besoin et d'y répondre
parfois même avec des moyens bricoler je
vais dire
et ça ça suffit parce qu'effectivement
c'est le plus important ça donne du sens
à l'action publique est aujourd'hui le
sens de l'action publique et je dirais
fortement appréciée bien sûr des
citoyens mais plus que cela
on considère que cette formule réagir
avec bon sens on se dit mais c'est une
formule un peu galvaudé non en temps de
crise
c'est ce qui vient en premier à l'esprit
des uns des citoyens à l'échelle
d'ailleurs locales régionales et c'est
même dire un peu un peu plus largement
dans l'ensemble de nos démocraties
donc ça c'est la proximité la proximité
c'est toutes les notions qui vont
toucher la question du soin prendre soin
de la bienveillance alors je sais que le
terme de bienveillance et est
aujourd'hui à des usages parfois trop
politisé mais c'est bien cela la
proximité la proximité c'est pas
simplement une question de distance
géographique c'est vraiment être au plus
proche
et puis la question de la compétence
bien on a vu qu au cours de cette crise
c'est probablement là où il y a je pense
que c'est là l'expression du décalage
c'est que cette cette compétence
on n'attend pas nécessairement d'un élu
local qu'ils aient une maîtrise totale
du code général des collectivités
territoriales qu'il n'est pas une
maîtrise totale du code de la santé
publique mais en revanche qu'ils
puissent effectivement joué un rôle à la
fois de celle d'hier de bousculer de
s'affranchir avec tous les risques
juridiques que vous avez
évoquer monsieur arnaud de s'affranchir
et de prendre des risques de
judiciarisation des actes que l'on
pourrait lui reprocher et effectivement
ça c'est scellier a la particularité de
la crise 2e deuxièmement la concision et
déjà entamé le je vois une difficulté
très très très grande
pendant cette crise je relisais
l'étrange défaite de marc bloch et quand
même on a tous les éléments qui étaient
posées dans dans cet ouvrage
bureaucratisation absence de révision
d'une doctrine alors là bien sûr on
parlait d'une doctrine militaire mais
finalement la doctrine d'action publique
elle peut aussi se décliner donc on a
considéré qu' une crise sanitaire valait
bien une autre crise et donc les mêmes
outils devaient être mobilisés
considérant que les outils et les
matériels d'une guerre victorieuse 14-18
pouvait être redéployés en 39 et 40
bon je trouve que cette crise a aussi
révélé puisque c'est votre point
ce sénateur qui l'armistice sur quels
termes on peut signer un armistice entre
les collectivités locales et l'état da
précisément dans cette dans ce
renversement de la verticalité jeudi
quand je parlais de coopération tout à
l'heure ça veut bien dire cela ça veut
dire que je suis pas un partisan de la
communalisation je pense qu'on doit
considérer que 35 mille ou un petit peu
moins mais 35000 commune
je n'ai aucun élément qui permettrait de
dire que c'est parce que nous avons 35
mille communes que la gestion de la
crise sanitaire à a pu être meilleure
que dans d'autres contextes
institutionnels en jeu ça je n'ai aucun
élément pour pouvoir vous confirmer ça
en revanche je peux vous dire que avoir
un état je prends l'exemple parce que
moi ça m'a beaucoup frappé j'ai vécu
pendant auprès de près de huit ans au
canada
j'ai suivi cette crise
sanitaires et je me souviens d'un débat
quand je vivais à montréal mouvements de
fusions et défusions des communes à
montréal dans le grand montréal
la raison principale du mouvement de
fusions c'était un principe de
rationalisation et de dire que
finalement il ya une économie de coût
qui peut être engagée parce que il ya
des dépenses assez lourde en raison de
des saisons et des opérations de
déneigement qui coûte beaucoup dans les
budgets des communes la diffusion était
président que il ya vu une contestation
sur le principe même de l'action
publique consistant à dire non on ne
peut pas avoir une égalité des moyens de
déneigement
parce qu'il ya des territoires beaucoup
plus résidentiels que d'autres et donc
dans une ges dans une crise de gestion
sanitaire on peut considérer on l'a vu
que la circulation du virus
ça je rejoins tout à fait le propos du
maire de dunkerque eu effectivement ces
signaux faibles
oui de une proposition sur cette boîte
cadets qui à mon avis est insuffisante
et le conseil d'état un avis certes
sévère mais je crois assez juste
d'ailleurs des 82 article je ne vois pas
un article parfaitement dédié à la santé
cohésion sociale cinq six articles mais
sur la santé stricto sensu
il n'y a strictement rien de bon si je
dois trouver une articulation entre une
amélioration institutionnels et cette
question précise de la santé alors oui
je considère que la coopération est ce
que ça passe recettes doit placer par
les opci je suis pas qualifié pour y
répondre mais en revanche une
coordination et une coopération mais
vraiment une coordination des de la
compétence santé allant de pair et moi
je trouve que c'est fondamental parce
qu'il n'y a pas de sens politique sans
responsabilité politique et il n'y a pas
de responsabilité politique sans
autonomie financière
le citoyen doit pouvoir apprécier
l'action qui est menée par le
responsable politique et cela doit
passer c'est quand même très curieux
sinon on va se retrouver toujours dans
cette situation c'est les choses n'ont
pas fonctionné c'est parce que l'état
n'a pas donné suffisamment de moyens
suffisamment de moyens et si les choses
et pour fonctionner c'est parce que le
responsable politique a fait preuve
d'une grande dune grande g agilité a
joué avec les moyens du bord bon ça
pas satisfaisant c'est ça qui mine notre
démocratie locale ont tiré la parra jeu
pour la donner à qui la souhaitent
monsieur le maire alain lambert qui qui
va intervenir monsieur le maire les i
oui merci merci rapidement d'abord sur
la question de du samu 15 % pour les
pour les élus locaux
moi j'ai eu le sentiment que la question
qui était posée n'était pas une question
posée sur la gestion de la crise mais
sur la sortie de crise qui me semble
assez du coup la réponse où elle ne va
pas choqué c'est la grâce à qui on est
en train de sortir de la crise moi
j'aurais dit d'abord les scientifiques
c'est-à-dire quand même celui retrouvé
le lac st ensuite évidemment la
population qui est largement après
longueur par contre si on avait posé la
question qui a amorti le choc de la
crise je pense que dans cette question
là je pense que les élus locaux aurait
été à mon avis plus haut que je me
demande si la question n'est pas aussi
un peu biaisé et et ne porte pas sur la
sortie de crise et non sur la gestion de
la crise et du choc
je reviens sur la question de
l'armistice rapidement
je pense que ce qui manque
fondamentalement aujourd'hui entre
l'état et les collectivités
c'est une reconnaissance d'un cadre
cohérent et assumée de ce qui relève de
l'égalité républicaine et de ce qui
relève de la différenciation quand je
parlais tout à l'heure de la gestion du
quotidien et de la prévention
il faut dire en français ça ça relève de
la différenciation et donc ce qui se
passera à calais sera différent de
l'inca et il faut l'assumer et les dire
comme ça voilà et de l'autre côté il
faut dire voilà ce qui relève de
l'égalité républicaine
et voilà ce que vous aurez que vous
soyez à calais ou à dunkerque wapo web y
ait et je pense que ce qui manque
aujourd'hui c'est ce cas là assumée
entre égalité républicaine et
différenciation territoriales on est
dans le flou perpétuelle en fait sur ces
questions là et je pense qu'il y a trois
grands domaines aujourd'hui dans
lesquels il faut vraiment avancer sur
cet armistice état collectivités tout à
l'heure j'ai cité la sécurité c'est en
cours et je
que c'est un bel exemple moi j'ai un
travail remarquable aujourd'hui qui se
fait entre l'état et les collectivités
entre police nationale et police
municipale sur la prise en charge de la
tranquillité publique de la sécurité
l'aide aux victimes
la ville est en train de s'engager dans
l'aide aux victimes on fait un travail
remarquable aujourd'hui entre l'état et
la collectivité sur ces questions de
sécurité je trouve que ça avance à une
vitesse remarquable et paca vainqueur
par contre dans la santé il se passe pas
grand chose parce que je le redis d'un
côté il ya la gestion de la maladie de
l'autre côté il ya plutôt les
problématiques de prévention et on ne
lit pas les 2 et l'éducation aussi qui
reste avec un retard schigand pèse quoi
il faut se battre comme un chien quoi
pour faire avancer l'accompagnement
éducatif des communes
or je pense que dans ces trois domaines
santé sécurité éducation on aurait
vraiment à assumer un cadre cohérent
égalité républicaine versus
différenciation territoriales ont là
encore aujourd'hui mois chez moi le
corps du masque ça devient un gag
ça devient un gars plus personne ne
respecte aujourd'hui la cantine
nationale plus personne j'avais le
préfet au téléphone je lui disais tu
sais tu veux pas modifier un peu ça
parce que là il ya une personne qui
respecte je vais pas dire ce que m'a
répondu le préfet mais bon mais grosso
modo on voit bien que à force de mettre
en place des règles qui ne correspondent
plus à la réalité ils finissent par une
discréditer et donc du coup après tout
est discréditée là on devrait renforcer
la communication sur le port du masque à
l'intérieur en ce moment là on perd tous
là on est en train de tout perdre parce
qu'on est discréditée alors que si on
renvoyait à des éléments de
différenciation sur le port du masque
aujourd'hui on aurait des choses adapté
à la réalité locale donc aujourd'hui il
ya vraiment à être très très clair dans
le partage des tâches et non pas le
partage des compétences et puis je finis
juste dernier point l'armistice ne peut
être que signé nouvelles signées que si
on arrête de ponctionner les finances
des collectivités
sinon c'est à marcher nulle ah excusez
moi mais moi je gère tous les ans des
baisses de financements et j'en ai marre
que je veux dire je ne fais que ça
je suis élu depuis 2014 chaque année on
me baisse mon budget donc à un moment on
veut pas signer un armistice canton
repos quand on sait qu'on peut fait les
poches pas à lui inscrit moi quelqu'un
qui me fait les poches peut pas signer
la paix avec lui donc à un moment donné
faut arrêter les intercommunalités
notamment sous confronté à toutes les
crises notamment la crise énergétique
écologique
maintenant la crise sanitaire et on nous
fait les poches
quoi donc à un moment donné ça suffit
pas le juge m'arrêter là merci je passe
la balle s'il le veut bien lambert oui
merci monsieur le président parce que
j'ai une très grande confiance dans le
professeur jean-marie pompiers pour
qu'ils mettent en forme juridique ce que
je pourrais avoir à dire s'ils ont
notamment sur une question du rapporteur
c'est pour cela que je préfèrerais
parler avant lui
je voudrais dire à me très très
cordialement que les résultats qui nous
a donné son scientifiquement absolument
exact mais je recommanderais très
vivement que les administrations
centrales n'en tire pas comme
interprétation qu'elles ont
magnifiquement travaillé parce que très
franchement si je comprends bien enquête
c'est que avant elle n'avait pas de
crédibilité maintenant ils en ont un peu
assez qu'on attend d'elle c'est qu'elle
tournait beaucoup donc je je crois que
pour faire très très attention les
administrations centrales de l'école ne
sont que plusieurs d'entre nous le
président a été lui-même au gouvernement
elles sont assez rapidement fait
satisfaite d'elle-même
donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'il faille
leur dire trop fort qu'elles ont
parfaitement bien travaillé sur le
deuxième point monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez évoqué la difficulté bien
française de pouvoir faire collaborer ou
faire arctique ou articuler la mission
des différents acteurs le professeur
jean-marie pottier est un grand
spécialiste
au plan juridique de ce sujet nous en
avons souvent parlé ensemble
ce que je crois c'est que l'instrument
le plus efficace dans ce domaine où les
politiques publiques sont conçus
verticalement
alors que pour pouvoir les rendre
efficaces il faut pouvoir les mettre en
oeuvre
horizontalement il ya l'instrument le
plus efficace
restera toujours le contrat c'est-à-dire
la contractualisation à condition que
les dés ne soit pas pipé avec des
contrats d'adhésion ou le pouvoir
exécutif définit les modalités du
contrat qu'ils vont organiser cette
articulation entre les différents
acteurs pour me tais pour mener
conjointement une action publique
je pense que le professeur frontier sera
mieux comme moi expliquer quels sont les
ressorts juridiques qui pourraient être
utilisés en la matière parce qu'il a
publié des articles très important sur
ce sujet mais je crois que c'est tout à
fait possible à condition qu'on accepte
l'idée d'une certaine liberté
contractuelle entre différents acteurs
avec en effet une différence selon les
territoires
à raison de la diversité de notre pays
s'agissant des normes elle même monsieur
le rapporteur vous allez très très bien
compris qu'à partir du moment où une
compétence et était totalement
transférer la tentation du service
central qui est en charge de veiller à
ce que cette compétence continue d'être
viennent exercer et de pouvoir réagir
dans l'idéal si j'ose dire sa manière
d'être mises en oeuvre sans se
préoccuper des coûts qui en résultent
ni de la complexité avec laquelle ces
normes vont s'appliquer et vous
comprenez bien que selon qu'il s'agisse
d'une commune de 500 habitants où d'une
ville comme comme comme dit le capital
ou régionales les modalités ne devraient
pas être les mêmes ou au sénat nous nous
battrons sur ce sujet je dois dire que
le partenariat que nous avons ouvert
avec notre homologue allemand nous
convainc tout à fait que l'uniformité
n'est pas une nécessité absolue
et je crois que nous pouvons en effet
arrivé à enfin discipline et la
production de ces normes s'agissant du
contentieux
soyons sérieux il y en a pas beaucoup en
tout cas ceux qui existent sont des
contentieux très spécialisées notamment
dans le droit de l'urbanisme
mais dans les normes qui pourrissent la
vie des collectivités locales
il ya très très peu finalement de
contentieux il ya des risques de
contentieux mais ça c'est la vie
s'agissant de l'armistice cher président
je n'ai utilisé au sens de la suspension
des hostilités lorsque vous avez
parfaitement expliqué qu'en effet depuis
lundi 30 ans il existe quand même entre
l'état central et les collectivités
territoriales des malentendus qui
s'enchaînent les uns derrière les autres
et à un moment donné il va falloir
chacun faire un pas vers l'autre
comme vous l'avait dit il ya un instant
et c'était l'esprit dans lequel je le
proposais et bien en effet le la loi
cadre et le support idéal pour pouvoir
signer ce niveau par a signé ce contrat
de deux nouveaux paradigmes entre l'état
et les collectivités territoriales
alors que de voir et élus contenir et il
devrait déjà par exemple contenir une
une explicitation de ce qu'est le
principe d'égalité je voulais proposer
tout à l'heure je vous ferai passer une
rédaction qui est tout à fait à part
fait probablement mais qui pointe les
sujets sur lesquels on rencontre une
pusillanimité incroyable des interprètes
de la loi alors que le conseil
constitutionnel n'a jamais parlé et m'a
ma conviction profonde c'est il faudrait
aller suffisamment loin il que le
législateur au regard de l'article 34 de
la constitution il suffisamment
suffisamment loin pour que le conseil
constitutionnel place les vrais bornes
en la matière du principe d'égalité
parce que il a vraiment besoin d'être
explicités il ya un autre principe qui
méritent d'être davantage à profond on
dit si celui de la libre administration
et ça dans la loi cadre et vous allez
pouvoir le faire dans la loi-cadre
également vous allez grâce à la
modulation des compétences pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre ce que le rapporteur
demandé en matière de l'articulation
entre les différents acteurs sur des
politiques qui sont conduites
conjointement je crois que cette loi
4d doit vous permettre puisque le
gouvernement dans sa rédaction initiale
on va dire a été modeste et bien aux
français
prenez le comme une invitation à
l'ambition pour le parlement de
reprendre au fond les doigts que la
constitution lui a conféré et il est le
seul d'ailleurs à déterminer les
conditions dans lesquelles les
collectivités territoriales exercent
leur leurs compétences et bien d'être
extrêmement ambitieux et de partir de
l'idée que le principe c'est la liberté
que la régulation c'est l'exception et
que finalement les seuls bornes réel qui
existe ce sont les libertés publiques et
les droits constitutionnellement
garantis et je ne suis sûr que le sénat
ne mesurera bien en l'espèce la grande
responsabilité constitutionnelle qui est
la sienne au garde sa représentation des
collectivités territoriales
quand je sors ton pied
oui monsieur le président en quelques
minutes très vite
d'abord je voudrais dire que je vais
tout à fait dans le sens de ce que vient
de dire monsieur le ministre lambert me
semble tout à fait d'accord sur ces
points je pense que alors qu'ils peuvent
parler très largement le projet de loi
4d tel qu'il existe actuellement le
sioniste envers a dit modeste
moi je dirais qu'ils n'apportent rien ce
serait beaucoup plus sévères sont au
parlement de prendre les mesures qui
conviennent pour rétablir cet équilibre
entre l'état et les collectivités
territoriales parce que le projet de loi
90 n'importe pas du tout de romain dans
aux difficultés qui existent
actuellement et il ne porte pas non plus
de solution aux inconvénients de la loi
l'autre parce que cette loi l'autre
selon moi c'est une loi qui est une
mauvaise loi inopportune sans doute
inutile et qui à compliquer
considérablement les choses sur le plan
par exemple de la contractualisation sur
laquelle le monsieur le ministre lambert
a justement attirer l'attention
regardez vous avez par exemple les
conventions territoriales d'exercice
concertée de la compétence mais
s'étaient eux c'est qu'est ce que c'est
personne ne le sait exactement
alors on ne sait tellement pas que
l'inspection généreux ministre
l'intérieur a demandé à l'inspection
générale de l'administration de faire
une recherche pour savoir comment ces
conventions fonctionner résultat on ne
sait pas très bien c'est très obscures
c'est extrêmement compliqué tout la loi
notre rêve est de 10 positions
compliquées et je crains si cela n'est
pas modifiée que le projet de loi
actuellement le projet de loi 4d
l'améliorant rien du tout et n'aggrave
même la situation alors juste un mot sur
la contractualisation évoqué qui est
effectivement quelque chose d'essentiel
souvent cette contractualisation entre
l'état les collectivités territoriales
qui est je crois qu il fit hôtels
d'accor la seule
lucio mais cette contractualisation est
souvent un faux semblants les élus
locaux se sentent souvent trompés
lorsque l'état vit en contractualise les
élus locaux pensent qu'il s'agit de
contrats mais ce n'est pas parce qu'on
appelle un acte contrat qu'il s'agit
d'un contrat et le jugeant le juge
administrative le conseil d'état souvent
requalifie ledit contrat anne acte
unilatéral
donc les élus locaux se sentent
littéralement cloué il me semble qu'il
appartient au législateur d'adopter des
dispositions pour faire en sorte que
cette contractualisation en soit
véritablement une et il y a des moyens
et suffire et au législateur de dire que
les contrats sont les contrats que le
juge administrative ne puisse pas aller
à l'encontre de cette qualification
il serait même possible au législateur
de dire ce sont des contrats au sens de
l'article 11 cents 1 du code civil qui
définit le contrat et ainsi le juge
serait pris par cette définition il ne
pourrait pas aller à l'encontre et je me
demande aussi toujours sur le plan de la
contractualisation
si le législateur ne pourrait pas
proposer un cadre de contractualisation
et des biens proposés dans lequel
pourrait s'inscrire les collectivités
territoriales qui voudraient
contractualiser avec l'état c'est qu'ils
laisseraient cette liberté aux
collectivités territoriales tout en
considérant qu'il s'agit bien de contrat
avec les conséquences sont attachées au
contrat c'est à dire que l'état s'il se
dédise et pourrait être responsable de
cette situation
voilà monsieur le président dit en
quelques mots très vite à bien merci
infiniment professeur bien je vais me
tourner vers les collectionneurs je vois
que muriel jourda se précipite sur son
micro ici pour aller plus vite que tous
les autres sénateurs présents mais suis
je suis le président
merci merci de deuil à parole dans ce
débat que je trouve très intéressant
j'ai beaucoup apprécié les échanges sur
sur la notion d'égalité pour ma part je
pense que l'égalité comprend la
différenciation parce que pour moi
l'égalité n'est pas traiter tout le
monde de la même façon mais de fixer un
but commun est dès lors les moyens pour
arriver ne sont pas nécessairement les
mêmes donc les deux notions ne me
paraissent pas ne me paraissent pas
impossibles à concilier et je trouve
également très intéressant sur le débat
sur la halle la contractualisation alors
je pense que le problème n'est pas
vraiment que les contrats ne sont pas
des vrais contrats c'est qu'on a surtout
une partie dans le contrat qui est en
situation léonine qui est l'état et qui
donc peut imposer ce qu'elle souhaite en
appelant sa contrat chacun se rappellera
le pacte de cahors qui prévoyait la
diminution des dépenses des
collectivités et en contrepartie de quoi
eh bien elle était mieux dotés il est
évident que là dedans on appelait ça des
contrats mais la réalité est que l'état
disait ce qu'il voulait et consignes et
on ne signez pas mais c'était la seule
attitude qu'on avait j'observe tout de
même que la liberté qui pour moi de bien
plus de résultats que la contrainte
n'est pas très bien vu de manière
générale par l'état et nous avions
notamment un outil entre collectivités
entre communes qui étaient extrêmement
efficace qui s'appelait le sivu syndicat
intercommunal à vocation unique qu'on a
supprimé au motif de supprimer est ce
qu'on appelait le millefeuille mais qui
en réalité était un outil très souple
qui répondait à des besoins locaux
il coûtait peu cher mais qui a été
supprimée par pur dogmatisme et je
crains fort que l'on soit toujours dans
cette dans cette vision des choses
alors j'avais quand même une question
parce que c'est pas moi qui suis
auditionné qui avait trait à
l'impression générale que j'ai eu comme
notre collègue jean michel arnaud mais
quand ce comme le lemaire maire de
dunkerque aussi sur le fait que dans
l'étude du cevipof
effectivement les maires ne sont pas
traités alors à leur juste valeur parce
que je ne sais pas si avoir 35 mille
communes en france nous a aidés mais ce
qui est certain c'est qu'à voir des
communes nous a aidés ce qu'on a tous pu
constater sur le terrain c'est que
lorsqu'il a fallu fournir des masques
les maires ont été bien plus efficaces
pour les commander ou pour les faire
fabriquer tout simplement sur place
quand on avait les moyens qu'on avait à
l'époque c'est à dire pas de possibilité
de commande dans le cas d'une pénurie
mondiale
qu'ils ont aussi été efficace pour faire
installer centres de vaccination parfois
en se battant pour ça il c'était une
lutte et qu'ils ont été efficaces
lorsqu'il s'est agi de recenser en
partie d'ailleurs sur le listing du plan
canicule les personnes qui étaient en
difficulté dans les communes pendant le
confinement en des appels ont été passés
par les élus locaux lé dé des courses
ont été livrés et puis ensuite vers la
fin et vers la vaccination est bien les
élus parfois contre l' ars ont mis en
place des transports pour pouvoir
emmener vers les centres de vaccination
des gens qui étaient dépourvus de moyens
de transport enfin c'est un témoignage
locale mais qu'on a tous connus je crois
dans nos départements
donc il est certain que les communes ont
pris une place primordiale alors je suis
d'accord avec monsieur maire de
dunkerque ça n'est pas choquant
lorsqu'on demande si mais les maires
sont responsables d'amélioration de la
situation sanitaire est ce que seuls 4%
des personnes interrogées estiment
qu'ils sont responsables de
l'amélioration
je suis assez d'accord pour dire que
c'est le vaccin qui va améliorer la
situation sanitaire de propos délibéré
que vous n'avez pas posé la question de
savoir qui a joué un rôle essentiel dans
la gestion de la pandémie qui n'est ni
son amélioration neeson aggravation mais
sa prise en charge tout simplement s de
propos délibéré ou tout simplement
n'avez vous pas envisager votre
questionnaire de cette façon
avant de donner la parole brièvement à
monsieur foucault moi je voudrais
rajouter juste un exemple qui vient de
se produire dans mon département et par
rapport à d'autres on nous dit non pas
de territorialisation donne un os non
c'est l'état qui décide c'est l'état
seul qui fixe les règles voilà très bien
le maire de levallois demande
l'ouverture le 20 mai de six manèges
jeux bien six manèges un pas pas
disneyland six manèges sur l'esplanade
devant la mairie de levallois refus
catégorique du préfet qui disent et non
pas avant la mi juin
et si vous le faites je vous traîne
devant les tribunaux pour mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui
dans le même temps on apprend le même
jour que à marseille au parc chanot
le salon de la gastronomie et du vin
avec 230 stand ouvre deux cent trente
stands de gastronomie et vin est à dire
où les gens par définition on enlève les
masques boivent et mangent
d'ailleurs on peut faire donc deux cent
trente stands à marseille avec des
milliers de personnes qui vont venir
boire et manger mais surtout pas si
petit tour de manège sur l'esplanade de
levallois quel est le sens profond
si on nous dit non la territorialisation
de la logique d'état en la matière c'est
absurde
je veux dire franchement un moment
l'état va lui même se perdre dans son
propre fonctionnement mais je vous
laisse la parole monsieur merci je n'ai
pas d'éléments très très profond vous
dire sauf que nous sommes en train de
travailler actuellement avec
l'association des maires de france sur
un complément assez sérieux de ce module
qui n'était pas dédié au rôle des élus
locaux dans la gestion c'est vraiment un
barreau mais sur la confiance et ont
regardé les éléments d'appréciation delà
de la confiance donc je suis vraiment
agnostique sur la sur la place sur la
question tout en sachant que ce qui sera
très important et juan en vous écoutant
je je je je je vais être très inspiré
sur cette question parce que vous avez
indiqué que pour vous égalité et
différenciation pouvait être compatibles
et l'exemple que vient de lui vient de 6
des sénateurs karoutchi est très
intéressant parce que au fond dans notre
à cette enquête baromètre confiance
politique mais on a près de 35% un tiers
des français qui sont très attachés à
l'égalité territoriale principe d'une
république égalitaire dès lors qu'elle
va de pair avec une mission de
correction des inégalités
c'est très important en revanche on voit
qu'il ya une tension réelle aujourd'hui
et ça notre enquête le met en évidence
on est prêt à abandonner le principe de
l'égalité territoriale
si cela va de pair avec plus
d'efficacité et pour moi cette question
de décentralisation au cette question de
différenciation doit effectivement posé
le principe de bien sûr de l'efficacité
mais dans l'efficacité c'est pas
seulement l'efficacité au sens
je dirais économique du terme c'est
aussi une efficacité politique et le
principe de réactivité
moi je l'associent au principe de
responsabilité et je crois
qu'effectivement la différenciation en
tout cas dans ce texte manque déjà
leader de peut-être de perspicacité ou
d'ambition ou d'audace pour restaurer ce
lien de responsabilités politiques
et quand vous dites vous avez tout à
fait raison peut-être que les français
n'ont pas dans cette enquête mis en
évidence le rôle joué par les élus
locaux dans la gestion c'est précisément
je pense que quand on décide de à ce
point de présidentialiser la gestion
d'une crise on peut difficilement pour
le citoyen qui est habitants de la
commune
moi qui surgirent de la bourgogne je
prends une une commune de bourgogne à
is-sur-tille par exemple eh bien si on
lui dit il ya une distribution de
masques
le citoyen ne va pas pouvoir séparer ce
qui relève d'une initiative du maire
pour se substituer à ce que l'état où le
préfet n'a pas su faire ou ce qui relève
d'une consigne est presque géré presque
d'un décret national et ça effectivement
au fur à mesure où je crois que
l'expression vider les poches employé
par le maire de dunkerque tout à l'heure
en termes de moyens bien au fur et à
mesure on continue dans cette logique
évidemment ça je trouve que l'on est en
train d corner le principe même de
responsabilité politique et on a besoin
de responsabilité politique pour le bon
fonctionnement d'une démocratie c'est
c'est le sait le b à ba du d'un système
politique en formant
[Musique]